les choses ne s'améliorent pas pour de
nombreux artisans et notamment de
nombreux boulangers qui sont dos au mur
après la crise énergétique et
l'augmentation des prix de l'électricité
ils ont appris que le bouclier tarifaire
ne concernerait plus les entreprises
alors on a décidé de faire un truc tous
les soirs les chéris pour faire bouger
les choses pour faire bouger le
gouvernement parce que j'ai vu que il
bouge beaucoup j'ai vu qu'hier il y
avait le ministre de l'éducation qui
était bloqué j'ai vu qu'il y avait la
ministre de la Culture qui était
débloqué alors que nombreuses
boulangeries ont déjà fermé nous voulons
continuer à alerter le gouvernement sur
le cas et sur le sur leur cas sur leur
détresse on va lancer tapant du pain sur
la table donc voilà on va lancer même en
hashtag etc vous vous Twitter sur insta
aussi il faut sauver nos boulangers on
va recevoir Roger et Jérémy Ferrer
boulanger depuis plus de 25 ans et
contraint de tirer le rideau voilà
encore une boulangerie qui ferme encore
aujourd'hui les chéris et ça ne bouge
pas ça ne fait rien on va perdre tous
nos boulangers sans compter tous les
mecs qui se retrouvent avec une famille
dans la merde donc je vous le dis
tapons du pain sur la table petit récap
ils sont avec nous juste après
ce week-end de le ministre de
l'Industrie Roland Lescure a fait une
déclaration qui va venir bouleverser le
quotidien de nombreuses entrepreneurs
d'électricité le gazon beaucoup baissé
qu'aujourd'hui les entreprises n'ont pas
besoin d'aide déployer en 2021 le
bouclier est tarifaire qui permettait
aux Français de faire face à la hausse
des prix de l'énergie vient donc d'être
levée pour les entreprises hier en
réponse à cette décision des boulangers
en détresse submergées par le coup des
matières premières et par leur facture
d'électricité qui explose était venu
crier lors désarroi sur notre plateau
l'arrêt du bouclier tarifaire mais on va
où quoi stop on va où beaucoup
d'artisans sont même aujourd'hui
contraints de baisser le rideau alors
très touché et préoccupé par ses
témoignages bouleversants Cyril Hanouna
et l'équipe de TPMP ont donc décidé de
leur venir en aide en lançant ce soir
l'opération tapant du pain sur la table
tu as pond du pain sur la table et on
fera beaucoup plus simple pour les
boulangeries on va on va je vous dis on
va durcir enfin durcir vraiment la
mobilisation la mobilisation durant les
prochains jours parce que c'est vrai
qu'on voit des boulangeries fermées tous
les jours on a accroché et Jérémy
artisan boulanger qui vont devoir
baisser le rideau Roger Jérémy vous
travaillez ensemble oui d'accord très
bien vous avez une boulangerie depuis
combien de temps
11 ans un mot 11 ans vous êtes c'est
votre c'est mon père effectivement
ça se passait bien oui ça se passe bien
effectivement on travaille en famille et
moi j'étais déjà venu ici en fait fin
octobre dénoncer tout ce qui est en
train de se passer exactement et manque
de bol en fait
on est là ce soir pas pour des bonnes
nouvelles finalement puisque dans 5
jours à la fin du mois on tire le rideau
définitivement c'est à cause de la
facture d'électricité
la dernière fois nous on était aux
alentours de 1500 euros par mois et là
en fait on sait manger un X 4 et demi et
avec les aides malgré les aides on fait
un X 3 et demi donc forcément
on peut pas assumer et comme je disais
c'est la goutte d'eau qui fait déborder
le vase il y a pas que ça mais moi ça me
rend fou Raymond tu vas dire encore ta
phrase on veut aider tout le monde mais
on laisse on laisse des des boulangers
qui sont vraiment des mecs qui
travaillent qui se réveille tous les
matins qui ont la passion de leur métier
on les laisse dans une merde noire on
les laisse voilà il va il va devoir
arrêter regardez Roger et Jérémy Jérémy
devait reprendre la boulangerie Roger il
travaillait depuis 11 ans tout se
passait bien on veut aider tout le monde
à l'arrivée on est personne très bien
depuis 11 ans et là ça marche plus alors
pourquoi ça marche plus parce que
l'électricité augmente pourquoi
l'électricité augmente on sait pas c'est
pas la faute d'un texte c'est pas la
faute de machin je sais pas c'est la
faute de qui en tout cas avant ils
arrivent à la faute mais c'est c'est
voilà on peut aider souvenez-vous moi il
y a un an ici j'avais dit c'est très
bien on va faire les choses c'est très
bien on va aider tout ce qu'on peut
aider parce qu'on est humain il y a pas
de problème mais j'avais dit cette
phrase j'avais dit ça va coûter cher
d'aider ça va coûter cher d'aider
l'Ukraine et Pierre Paul Jacques et
c'est très bien d'aider le monde entier
moi je veux bien aider le monde entier
il y a pas de souci mais le problème
c'est que je veux pas que les gens les
Français qui travaillent ici en France
crève de faim et des salariés au
chômage parce que là on voit deux
personnes mais dans une boulangerie
parfois il y a 10 15 salariés par des
boulangers il y a aussi d'autres TPE il
y a aussi d'autres entreprises qui vont
mettre la clé sous la porte et c'est des
salariés qui vont se retrouver au
chômage et c'est des familles qui vont
crever alors moi je suis d'accord pour
aider le monde entier il y a pas de
problème là-dessus c'est pas c'est pas
négociable on va aider le monde entier
mais faut pas laisser crever les gens
qui sont ici aussi ça veut dire même il
y en a pour qui c'est déjà trop tard et
énormément pour qui c'est déjà trop tard
déjà je vous dis voilà regardez Roger
Jérémy c'est déjà trop tard pour vous
puisque vous me dites quoi vous allez
fermer la boulangère dimanche dimanche
est-ce qu'il me fout les boules en fait
c'est que ben moi j'ai 32 ans donc ça va
je pourrais rebondir en revanche pour
mon père et ma mère 59 ans aller
chercher du boulot à 59 ans quand vous
avez été patron tout votre vie pardon
c'est un peu compliqué mais alors si
vous allez faire mais on va chercher du
travail
c'est incroyable un jour ça me rend fou
et donc c'est juste à cause de
l'électricité parce que franchement 4 et
demi comment tu veux t'en sortir
tu peux pas faire un business plan un
bilan sur un truc où tu sais que tu vas
voir 4 fois et demi d'électricité pas
possible et qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit on
vous dit quand on vous dit on vous aide
au lieu de faire ah c'est pas faute
d'avoir dénoncé tout ça depuis le mois
d'octobre on a été reçu à Bercy on a été
reçu par Olivia Grégoire etc mais au
final on nous écoute mais on nous entend
pas en fait il y a rien qui se passe
mais et donc ils vous ont dit quoi qui
nous entendait qui prenait note pour
autant rien ne change le syndicat de la
boulangerie également est monté au
créneau mais ça se demandait si
finalement il défendent pas plutôt leurs
intérêts que les intérêts des boulangers
moi je finis par me demander en fait je
me pose la question non mais les
boulangeries les les gens qui
travaillent les boulangers c'est la
France c'est c'est
exactement au patrimoine de l'unescence
crever les artisans boulangers
tu comprends pas là c'est sûr que les
matières premières ont augmenté la
farine la levure le sucre et tout ça
peut augmenter il se plaignent pas de ça
les boulangers à chaque fois ils savent
que le beurre augmente c'est
l'électricité surtout le plastique a
augmenté l'emballage à chaque fois qu'on
reçoit des boulangers des boulangers me
parle sur Instagram c'est pour me dire
l'électricité j'ai été à 2000 je suis à
9000 mais comment tu es à 4000 je suis à
10000 comment tu vas faire c'est c'est
comment comment tu veux t'en sortir
quand tu passes de 2000 à 8000 en
électricité c'est impossible c'était
obligé de faire mais tu perds de
l'argent tous les mois tu vas pas vendre
tu vas pas vendre des millions de
baguettes qui prennent sur quatre roues
non mais tu vois pas terrible le crime
en fait pourquoi on laisse faire ça
c'est ce que vous dites à chaque fois
Géraldine parce qu'en fait c'est juste
tellement absurde le crime bah je vais
te le dire c'est comme ça dit pareil sur
les retraites à cryptrophique le crime
t'a dit bah je comprends ce que tu dis
mais c'est que bah je te dis c'est sûr
on marche sur la tête ici
les boulangers que les retraites mais
les deux sont absurdes pas pour moi mais
voilà les deux sont absurde et de son
absurde puisque ça fait 40 ans qu'on
nous dit tu as
aujourd'hui pourquoi aujourd'hui il y a
les gens ne s'en sortent pas avec
l'électricité c'est à cause de quoi moi
qu'on m'explique
moi pour me semble j'ai eu une
possibilité de réponse une éventualité à
l'époque Monsieur Hollande faire plaisir
à la gauche oui je sais aux écolos et
ben ils ont fait fermer les centrales
nucléaires c'est la deuxième raison la
première raison c'est du crâne c'est pas
la première raison c'est l'Ukraine la
deuxième raison c'est des centrales
nucléaires qui ont fermé ils sont en
train d'essayer d'en ouvrir là
actuellement
mais ça suffira pas la raison numéro une
c'est l'Ukraine des régions numéro 2 les
les centrales nucléaires
toujours des bonnes idées qui a donc
fait plaisir à tout le monde et qui a
fermé des centrales nucléaires bah
pourtant lui il a aimé bien les
croissants donc forcément c'est tiré
c'est tiré une balle dans le cul tout
seul non mais je te le mets amener des
croissants ces meufs oui il y a la
dictature de l'Europe aussi Cyril quand
même parce que le les tarifs de
l'électricité c'est quand même l'Europe
la fin du bouclier tarifaire c'est parce
que l'Europe dit le guichet va jusqu'à
la fin 202 3 et après on arrête donc à
un moment peut-être qu'il faudrait
s'affranchir de cette tutelle pesante
parce que au moment du quoi qu'il en
coûte il y avait pas le poids de
l'Europe on s'en foutait on a payé pour
les restaurateurs et c'est tout à fait
normal dans ce problème là puisqu'ils
sont sortis de l'Europe et s'en sort pas
beaucoup mieux
de l'Europe à un moment je trouve
la France a un des piliers de l'Europe
donc aussi tu vois on est on est
clairement les acteurs principaux avec
les Allemands donc on va pas détruire
l'Union européenne
vous savez moi j'ai dû fermer mes
entreprises aussi à cause de plein de
choses dont l'électricité moi j'avais
des centres d'électrons simulation que
j'ai dû fermer parce que je m'en sortais
pas et c'était très conseillé et donc il
y a trois mois j'ai dû tout arrêter j'ai
tout fermer tout tout ce que j'avais
construit tous mes rêves là-dessus j'ai
dû arrêter donc c'est compliqué pour
pour plein de de d'entreprise pas que
les boulangeries et et c'est l'État
devrait nous aider c'est évident que il
va se passer des choses je vais te dire
là à chaque fois qu'il y a un problème
on nous dit c'est l'Europe ça c'est
devenu le nouveau truc tu sais c'est
comme voilà c'est comme compter avec ta
mère et ton père problème dans ces ta
mère qui veut pas c'est toujours pareil
c'est toujours l'Europe il y a toujours
un truc c'est toujours le même et
l'Europe ils veulent pas l'Europe et le
pain tiens il y a il y a tiens tu sais
quoi il y a mon ami il y a kacoubi qui
travaille avec moi qui ai une idée
magnifique que je lance tout de suite on
va lancer tout de suite un fond de
solidarité pour redistribuer au
boulanger en difficulté on va appeler ça
le traduit-on
c'est une cagnotte on va lancer une
cagnotte litchi on va essayer de
redistribuer au boulanger on va essayer
de faire ça dès demain bien sûr on
mettra déjà direct dans la cagnotte pour
essayer de voilà de lancer le truc pour
essayer de sauver nos boulangers voilà
alors on pourra peut-être pas sauver
tout le monde on va essayer de le faire
avec vous forcément qui nous écoutait
parce que c'est vrai que si chacun met
un euro mine de rien pourra peut-être
sauver nos boulangeries et nous
boulanger mais c'est dingue qu'on en
arrive
ici on a pas besoin d'aide on veut juste
payer le bon prix on continue à payer et
basta je sais mais à un moment il faut
bien que là si on peut vous donner on va
essayer
je vous parle voilà et on a l'idée à
l'instant avec mes équipes donc voilà
c'est juste que un moment c'est moi chez
moi ça m'en fous moi je vous dis ça me
rend fou de voir Roger qui va se
retrouver à chercher du travail à 59 ans
mais c'est que mon marche sur la tête
excusez-moi pour aider
on devient fou dans ce pays ce pays tout
marche à l'envers excusez-moi c'est
c'est n'importe quoi et c'est très grave
ce qui se passe parce que ça fait des
semaines qu'on reçoit des artisans des
boulangers qui viennent nous dire avant
même de parler de fermeture ce qui est
dramatique je ne me paye pas je gagne
pas ma vie je gagne 0 € et c'est devenu
en un coup c'est devenu une norme en
fait qui ont des boulangeries ou des
entreprises des artisans de ne pas se
payer donc au-delà des boulangers qui
sont la fierté de la France on dégoûte
les gens de l'entrepreneuriat tous les
gens vont dire ben non je vais aller me
trouver un taf à devenir salarié alors
que c'est vous devriez non seulement
gagner votre vie mais bien gagner votre
vie vous êtes entrepreneur vous êtes
passionné vous prenez des risques et
vous êtes récompensés en étant gagné 0
en payant en étant payé 0 € et en allant
prendre dans vos économies c'est
n'importe quoi et c'est on va dégoûter
les Français de tout l'entrepreneuriat
avec ça il faut absolument que ça change
c'est dramatique si c'est pas fait
exprès finalement est-ce qu'on veut pas
tuer finalement le l'artisanat les
entreprises je sais pas je sais pas mon
père il se crève ils se crève le cul 80
heures par semaine 59 ans et au final
comment le remercie 25 ans qu'il a son
compte et comment le remercie
aujourd'hui bah il repart avec une main
devant une main derrière il va chercher
du boulot à 59
on en peut plus c'est insupportable on
marche sur la tête et on se demande en
fait la même chose certainement vous
dites comment se fait-il que ça ne bouge
pas c'est un truc de fou c'est comme il
y a une énorme urgence sur les
agriculteurs je vous le dis les
agriculteurs dans 6 mois vous allez voir
vous allez voir les agriculteurs vous
allez voir aussi personne n'en parle
tout le monde s'en fout vous allez voir
un moment vous allez on va plus on va
avoir plus on va plus avoir un produit
mais tout le monde s'en fout en plus si
on commence à laisser crever les
agriculteurs les boulangers
les restaurateurs à la raison exactement
c'est vrai les restaurateurs les
e-commer les gens les mecs qui avaient
des boîtes de nuit aussi ils sont pendus
avec le premier prix c'est c'est
franchement je vous le dis c'est
n'importe quoi et on veut continuer à
aider tout le monde à un moment
frérot un moment il y a des priorités
excuse-moi oui oui il y a aussi Cyril
par rapport à l'électricité les
profiteurs de crise à un moment on dit
ça les fournisseurs d'énergie le
gouvernement devaient leur taper dessus
il avait négocié il avait dit vous
pourrez les boulangers pour renégocier
les contrats avec une hausse limitée
pour que ceux qui vous ont fait signer
des contrats à un moment probabilité
soit sanctionnés mais ça ça n'a pas eu
lieu ça n'a pas l'impression qu'on a
rien fait le gouvernement ne fait que
des effets d'annonce c'est ce que des
feux des fausses promesses pardon et en
plus de ça il y a certains boulangers
qui avaient trouvé la parade ils étaient
passés sur des tarifs bleus pour
bénéficier au même titre que les
particuliers du bouclier tarifaire sauf
que la double peine c'est que là hier
ils ont pris la parole le gouvernement
et ils ont dit que le bouclier tarifaire
pour les professionnels et ben en fait
c'était fini à la fin d'année donc les
mecs ont payé un changement de compteur
on renégocier leurs tarif et finalement
ben plus de bouclier tarifaires à la fin
d'année donc finalement ils vont faire
comme nous ils vont fermer alors on
parlait on est en train de travailler en
mesure sur le traduit actuellement on
sait pas balancer vraiment ce qu'on
aimerait nous c'est pas la même tous les
mecs qu'on connaît tous les artistes
tout ça qui mettent on va mettre bien
sûr de l'argent dedans on va voir
comment on peut mettre ça en place très
vite et que tous les artistes qu'on
connaît etc il y a bouder qui me dit par
exemple moi je veux mettre quelque chose
voilà qu'on tous quelque chose après
voilà moi parce que c'est vrai qu'on
demande énormément de français je vous
dis les Français ils en peuvent plus on
leur donne partout un moment les
Français ils peuvent pas sauver tout le
monde non plus un moment ils veulent ils
veulent qu'on les aide aussi donc c'est
c'est c'est c'est compliqué pour eux on
leur demande tout le temps on leur
demande des choses et voilà après je
vais vous dire là aujourd'hui tout
marche à l'envers et on voit qu'il y a
que des donneurs de leçons si on le sait
on le voit qui le font rien pour
personne hein je sais pas ce que vous
avez déjà été reçus sur une autre radio
sur un truc ah ben à quel niveau non
mais vous pour dire médiatique
depuis le mois d'octobre en fait on
enchaîne les plateaux télé pourtant oui
ah ben on a fait plusieurs plusieurs
émissions BFM France 2 etc vous avez été
reçu sur Radio France pas ma
connaissance puisque c'est les amis de
la mini saison qui allez recevoir donc
qui parle avec les ministres radio
France Inter là tout ça là mais pour
autant
ça change rien regardez vous avez été de
reçu par la mise à Grégoire Bruno Le
Maire je devrais pas dire ça
moi moi je vous dis ce qu'on m'a dit on
m'a dit un moment et je devrais pas le
dire mais on va dire un moment peut-être
qu'il faudrait que vous dites pas pour
l'instant on peut pas payer
l'électricité
coupée vous allez voir ça va être
compliqué je vous le dis à un moment
même voilà lisse et c'est compliqué à un
moment un moment les mecs il faut qu'il
vous aident et le gouvernement et Oliver
Grégoire elle est super en plus je vous
le dis mais elle y arrive pas elle y
arrive pas à un moment faut qu'elle
aille voir les fournisseurs d'énergie je
vous le dis alors dit c'est terminé et
voilà c'est ce prix là c'est fini sinon
je vais aller vous mettre une taxe sinon
je vais vous mettre une taxe vous allez
voir vous allez payer beaucoup plus que
ce que vous payez maintenant et donc il
vaut mieux que vous fassiez comme on dit
pour l'instant vous pour l'instant il
faut qu'il vende après coupon c'est
simple il faut qu'ils vont après coûtant
et on peut pas se faire de l'oseille
alors qu'il y a des mecs qui sont en
boulangerie qui sont en train de mourir
tu dis aujourd'hui voilà tu as le
gouvernement il dit demain écoutez moi
bien terminé c'est à prix coûtant voilà
c'est tout c'est simple c'est clair non
mais c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible de faire ça mais bien
sûr parce que vous avez raison pour
justifier l'arrêt du bouclier pour les
entreprises le gouvernement a dit ils
n'ont plus besoin d'aide le prix de
l'électricité et du gaz est à la baisse
ce qui n'est pas répercuté sur vos
factures donc ça veut dire que le vrai
prix il est beaucoup plus bas que ce
qu'on paye c'est ça sur incroyable donc
il faut faire le content ça baisse au
niveau mondial pourquoi en France nos
artisans ne bénéficient pas de cette
baisse
le gouvernement et je vous jure que
c'est vrai il aimerait je pense que
l'hiver Grégoire elle a envie de dormir
ça mais le problème c'est que j'ai
l'impression que impuissant il faut
taper du point sur la table à un moment
les mecs tu leur dis c'est comme ça
c'est autrement sinon je t'explique je
vais te mettre un impôt tu vas voir ce
que tu vas payer tu vas comprendre
ou un truc comme ça tu vas voir en
attendant on est tous en train de crever
exactement
de quoi tu vas faire quoi Jérémy ah ben
moi je vous avoue que j'ai sécurisé j'ai
repris un CDI en plus de ma boîte
d'accord donc comme je disais tout à
l'heure moi j'ai 32 ans donc ça va sauf
que mon père qui a 59 et ma mère qui a
59 également ça risque d'être un peu
plus compliqué non mais je vous jure on
dit un fou on devient fou Roger
c'est vrai garde le moral quand même il
faut le garder
on est solidaire avec nous deux enfants
et nous soutiennent
il faut le garder ils disent quoi les
clients de la boulangerie mais ils sont
ils sont désemparés ils sont tristes
puisqu'on était boulangerie un petit peu
familiale bien sûr il y a beaucoup de
mamies de
imaginez toutes les personnes qui
étaient certainement c'est leur
quotidien c'était là le rendez-vous
qui est plus la boulangerie dans
certains villages dans certaines villes
dans cette dernière c'est un truc en
rituel ils vont ils vont chez le
boulanger avec lui ils achètent on était
là pour le covid et bon maintenant
et les grandes surfaces elles vont
continuer à vendre du pain
autre problème un moment on peut pas
c'est joli voilà ma maman les grandes
surfaces aussi et le pain dans les
grandes surfaces et je le dis les
dégueulasse voilà les gars je vous le
dis tu manges le pain frère tu es sûr
d'aller aux toilettes donc non mais
c'est vrai donc arrêtez les gars faut
arrêter c'est des gens comme ça qu'il
faut qui faut sauver voilà grande
surface c'est très bien on a besoin
aussi pour les grandes surfaces il faut
aussi du pain pour tout le monde
c'est pas pour ça que c'est moins cher
mais je te le dis pas pour ça que c'est
moins cher je te le dis il y a du pain
parfois j'ai vu du pain en grande
surface qui était aussi cher que dans
des boulangeries et tu vois tu vois le
plein frère tu pleures c'est l'élastique
non mais je te le dis faut arrêter de
nous prendre pour des cons euh Jérémy et
Roger on voulait vous avoir ce soir je
suis un peu désemparé parce que je sais
même pas convenir parce que
le sort est scellé et je sais que vous
êtes venu aussi pour vous battre
peut-être pour vos collègues on
continuera à se battre pour pour nos
confrères mais en fait voilà moi ce que
je voulais c'est vraiment montrer ce que
le gouvernement a mis en place c'est que
en fait on abandonne un monsieur de 59
ans qui a été finalement entrepreneur
toute sa vie et maintenant il repart
comme je le dis comme je le disais tout
à l'heure pardon il repart avec une main
devant une main derrière donc merci en
tout cas c'est un super tu as vraiment
d'entendre c'est insupportable merci
Jérémy merci Roger merci d'avoir